hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today I hope you all had a
good happy 4th of July but for today I
wanted to talk about law breakers and
whether or not you should buy this game
or not so let's get started
so to summarize law breakers is an arena
shooter made by bosky productions with
two factions and nine roles with each
role looking different depending on the
team you play as the game is also going
to be costing you only thirty dollars
with no season pass because all future
content is free just exactly like
titanfall 2 it also comes with a $40
version that is just new skins for some
other characters and that's really it
for the extra $10 if you aren't already
hooked on this game just because of that
sentence then let's talk about some
characters then just starting at the
beginning we have Vanguard your basic
character if you don't play a lot of PC
games or are really good with shooter
games Vanguard is your character for you
to play an easier way into lawbreakers
she comes equipped with a machine gun
that gets more accurate the longer you
shoot and her alt fire is a blowback
mechanic allowing you to push enemies
away from you her ultimate is where she
flies into the air and slams onto a
targeted area and does tons of AoE
damaged and leaves behind a zero-g field
for a bit of time allowing her to move
around her mobility which is her main
source of power here is her jet pack
that basically boosts her like a jet and
makes her flyer on the map the next
character up is enforcer the only
difference between him and Vanguard is
that he requires tons more aim than
usual he comes equipped with a precision
rifle and a secondary pistol that acts
kind of like the plasma gun from dead
space where you can change the direction
where you want to shoot it with a
horizontal or vertical his two abilities
are an EMP grenade preventing the enemy
team from using their abilities if hit
by it and he's seeking rockets that can
kill most characters and about all three
hits his mobility skills the super
sprint that when activated makes him
faster and he also does more damage the
two enemies when he's in this mode I do
be aware though that this ability does
run out super quickly which is the only
downfall but it's for balance purposes
Titan is your standard Ezzor is going to
be the next class and he's your standard
heavy class with slow mobility and a
high damage output and it's equipped
with a rocket launcher one of my opinion
or the my only problem with this class
is how slow he is and he is one of the
only classes with
no mobility such as like a jetpack or a
sprint although I haven't gotten it down
yet Titan can rocket jump out of spawn
without dealing any damage to himself
kind of like the soldier from tf2 which
gives him enough speed to not be behind
in a firefight after death but his other
two abilities are a gravity grenade that
sucks in players and traps them for an
easy kill and his ultimate makes him
grow in size regenerate some of his help
and shoot electricity out of his hands
dealing massive damage to enemies making
him a very threatening target next
character on the list we have is
assassin a very mobile class using a
grapple hook to swing around the map
using a blade and a shotgun but to be
honest with this new patch before the
beta the shotgun is pretty weak although
on the other hand the blade rips through
characters like nothing I personally
feel that the blades do too much damage
they do about 150 damage per swing or
per hit and that can rip most classes up
in about 3 hits but that's just me
anyway she has two other abilities that
one is a grenade worth when thrown does
damage it hits a character and then
activates a zero-g field for her to
float in and her ultimate also when
activated gets her more speed and more
damage off her blades immediate after
immediate activation overall good
character but the blade damage is my
only issue but I feel like they'd
patched that eventually battle medic as
told by the name is going to be the
healer of lawbreakers equipped with a
grenade launcher and a fast firing
flyzone pistol uses her drones to heal
people and even pops a shield for the
players to sit in if you don't have a
very good skill or aim with the PC
characters such as myself battle medic
is another really good pick for you on
top of Vanguard her grenade launcher is
very forgiving with a good blast radius
and does decent damage if you miss the
target but landed near them her pistol
secondary does a lot of damage as well
if you hit all shots fired and once
again another good and balanced
character next up is juggernaut
juggernaut is a robot equipped with a
powerful shotgun and can deploy a
barrier to wall off choke points
preventing a push by the enemy team
juggernaut is like the battle medic in
terms of balance and seems in a good
spot but my only concern is his high
dependence on his ultimate to much see
his ultimate allows him to take less
damage
it's basically an extra extra coat of
armor for him
but he relies on it I feel that he needs
to rely on it way too much to do
anything and be useful yes the ability
recharges immediately after use but when
you're in a 2v1 you're almost guaranteed
death even with the ultimate activated
so we're going to relies on this
ultimate too much to survive and it
doesn't really help this class and
that's my only really issue with him
other than that he's a great character I
like his abilities just maybe tweak his
his his alt maybe maybe do more damage
with it or something to make him a
little less on the lower side the next
class up we have his gunslinger my least
favorite and my least play class now
hear me out though he is equipped with
two dual pistols equipped with dual
pistols one full auto and one revolver
personally for me though I do not like
this character I don't play a lot of PG
PC games so much as I've clearly stated
so my name is very piss-poor causing me
to miss easy shots and get kill very
often he's probably a good character in
the right hands but only if you really
have good aim
his recoil doesn't drop it or his recoil
doesn't get bigger anywhere like the
range of spread at all it just stays
perfectly centered so that's probably
one of the reasons why I can't really
hit too many shots although I did do
alright I'm not exactly a top-tier
player with him his abilities are though
a nice day when thrown can do damage the
enemies and when stuck to a nearby wall
can see enemies through walls to
understand you get him and get an
understanding of his next move his
ultimate also allows him to do a dual
wield with his pistols for insane damage
but cannot be cancelled when started and
you can't stop firing once activated for
his mobility he has a teleport similar
to tracer from overwatch to get him out
of nasty situations and that's about it
race is the last class for today and so
far in the game and most people
including myself he feels a bit
overpowered now I know it's only a beta
and I can't really you can't really
start calling things too hard or too
overpowered or too underpowered just of
yet but there's a bit of reasoning for
this he's got super fast mobility almost
on par with us Astin and paired that
with a fast full auto pistol that does
crazy damage and he's the outcome I have
a feeling Baskerville will tone him down
but for now he seems too overpowered at
the moment and I'm not the only one
that's that agrees with this
race abilities though are a knife that
shoots an explosive that when shot does
nice damage to unsuspecting enemies and
does damage if you stick them to it
it can only be blown up though with if
by shooting it or by letting it just
stay idle for about five seconds his
ultimate is a sonic pulse that when hits
that when is hitting an enemy that will
slow all their movement speed and
shooting speed allowing for a quick and
easy kill and for his mobility he has a
slide that shoots him forward in to gain
extra speed in a fight and also does
damage if connected with an enemy you
can you can pair this up with a slide
into a jumping it's him insane mobility
in a very same damage an unsuspecting
enemy that has no idea you're coming for
it
there's also another character that was
locked during the beta the name is
Harrier but the character isn't really
in debate at the moment so there wasn't
much info on the class all I know is
that I believe it's a she and she comes
equipped with a laser gun that shoots a
beam in a straight line that's all I
really know about her maybe there's more
info but as for right now that's all I
know is her weapon regarding the maps
the maps feel great in the game multiple
access points into rooms enough space to
have air combat but not overdoing it and
even the game moving has their own RNG
system called stash crates that you get
one every time you rank up and when you
open crates you get purely cosmetic
items only
nothing pay2win such as stickers and
skins for characters and weapons there
isn't any news of buying these stash
crates yet all we know is that you can
just get them from levelling up but that
was the beta it would be kind of useless
to buy stash crates during a beta in
terms of matchmaking though games are
found within seconds and it's very
fluent and with Riku in two other
matches and those were some of the
positives of this game in terms of the
negatives there isn't too much and it's
just my personal opinion on this though
the skill level needed for some
character is a bit high such as gum
flinger but that all comes with just
practice it might also be hard to adjust
if you're an Xbox player like myself
moving to PC because there is no Xbox
releases of yet and we're not really
accustomed to playing on a mouse and
keyboard as we are as we are with a
controller it'll probably take me a
while to get better at accuracy but for
right now I'm not exactly the greatest
for the gameplay you're seeing though
this is about three or four days in the
beta playing basically nothing but the
game for three to four days straight so
hopefully it wasn't too shitty to watch
summarize the game though the game feels
great aside from a few classes the
characters all feel fluent enjoyable and
balanced same for the maps as well
and for $30 no season pass and all
future content available with no payment
why would you not buy this game also
feel like though it's going to be like
another titanfall in terms of a it's
going to get a big community but nothing
huge is like overwatch or a really big
group of like cod or battlefield players
but I feel like it's going to still keep
pushing out content for the next five to
six months who knows maybe it won't
maybe we'll just have to wait and see
that's just my opinion though I hope you
all did enjoyed this and hopefully you
will join me in law breakers or at least
give it a try once the game comes out
there be tons more content to be made on
this game and I cannot wait to share all
with you so if the video is a bit long
I'm not too big on making long videos
but if you did enjoy like the video
dislike it if you didn't and comment
below your favorite characters so far
judging by what I've said by these
characters and the game players seeing
or if you've already played the beta and
you already got your main picked out I'd
love to know and subscribe for more
lawbreakers content and I'll see you
guys later peace out